[Music]
don't forget to enter our amazon gift
card giveaway all you have to do is be a
subscriber like and comment
hey guys going into the game of thrones
finale we have been teased about
reappearance of one particular character
who will supposedly leave us in shock to
see him
or her again now i know there has not
been any mention of surprising
reappearance in the season 8 episode 6
splat leak
but that doesn't necessarily mean there
won't be because there's a high
possibility that the league did not
cover every single event we are going to
see in the finale
don't get me wrong i'm not questioning
the legitimacy of the leak i talked
about a few days ago because it's legit
i'm just saying they might have missed
something or did not write everything
with that being said let's take a look
on the entertainment vehicle teaser
about this mysterious character that
will reappear in the finale
they reported from season 8 episode 6
filming set
what's being filmed here is episode 6
the series finale
like harrington going into the table
read i don't know anything about the
final season storyline
i look around at a meticulously
constructed set that i've never seen on
the show before
several actors are performing and i'm
stunned they're characters in the finale
that i did not expect
i gradually begin to piece together what
has happened in maestro's of the
previous 5 episodes
and try not to look like i'm freaking
out it's noted that there are characters
in the last episode of game of thrones
he did not expect
now we don't know if this means there
are characters we did not expect in
terms of them surviving the long
or if it means there are some unexpected
characters reappearing in the very last
episode
it could very well be just one of the
main characters surviving more than we
expected
but would he really leave the reporter
stunned he is stunned he is freaking out
about his character appearing in a
series finale
meaning that it's probably a character
no one expects coming back in the series
ever again
additionally i think it's probably a
character who we think is dead
reappearing
and leaving us in shock in this video
we're going to talk about the
possibility of rhaegar targaryen coming
back in the series finale
we're going to talk about rhaegar
targaryen is alive theory
rhaegar targaryen the son of the maid
king brother of daniel and father of jon
snow basically one of the most important
characters
in game of thrones history is not dead
but is rather alive and vel
and is one of the faceless men of
brahmos that's the theory i'm going to
introduce you with in this video
when you look at it rhaegar targaryen
and jackie hagar have a lot of
similarities
fans mostly point to the fact that both
of them share the same grace
and have the same long wavy hair if
joking does indeed turn out to be rehgar
the silvery streak in his hair would not
be the only indication
as there are many more clues in both the
books and the show series
i know that at first glance this might
sound impossible or even ridiculous
but i highly suggest you to hear out all
the clues and some kind of pro that's
going favor to this theory
let's start from the very beginning from
rengar's alleged death
the story says prince rhaegar met lord
robert baratheon in combat at the fort
during the battle of the trident
where the pair had a legendary duel in
the raging rivers of the trident
rhaegar despite wounding robert was
struck down with a massive blow from
robert's warhammer
which scattered the rubies encrusted in
rhaegar's armor under the water
it's said that rubies flew like drops of
blood from the chest of a dying prince
and he sang to his niece in the water
and with his last breath
murmured the woman's name while rhaegar
laid dead in the stream soldiers so both
armies scrambled in the water
to search for the rubies later the
location was named the ruby ford
according to a semi-canon source
regular's body was cremated
as the traditional for fallen targaryens
let's firstly point out the obvious
it's especially highlighted that rhaegar
wore his iconic knight black plate armor
with the three-headed dragon of house
targaryen decorated in rubies on its
breastplate
additionally the fourth image this
battle took place is named for the
rubies that were knocked from prince
rhaegar's breastplate
now why is it so important for george
armon as well as for the shove runners
to make it very clear that rhaegar wore
his iconic armor that had rubies
attached to it
why so much focus on regards rubies why
is it such a big
plot point and subject brought up
whenever the battle the trident or
rhaegar brought up
the first theory would be that robber
did not fight rhaegar but rather someone
else who had glamored himself in the
form of rehgar using rubies
as he was confirmed in the sixth season
rubies can be used to glamor its owners
into a form or person they want to be
melisandre uses it to hide her true form
of an extremely old woman
in the books men's raider glamour to
appear as rattleshirt
by other rule being his risk-off the
power in rubies is something called
glamour
where you can basically use them with
the power of lord of light to project a
different image of yourself
if melistanija and mans can use that
it's most certainly not out of the realm
of possibilities that someone had
glamored himself into the form of
rhaegar
using these same rubies and sacrificed
his life for beloved prince
the other theory that is also supported
with quite a bit of clothes says that
someone else died instead of rhaegar
wearing his iconic armor remember that
in books because he had been covered
from head to toe in armor
then he did not see his face in the
vision what i'm proposing in both
theories is that rhaegar never died on
the trident
and that he's the faceless man that we
know as jackie hagar
in both theories rhaegar also never
actually fought robert
while in the first one it was someone
else who used rubies to glamour himself
in the form of rhaegar
in the second one he was simply one of
the king's guard members who fought
robert
dressed up in rehgar's full armor
throughout the books we have been given
more than a few major examples of an
ordinary fighter wearing his hero's
armor
to sacrifice his life for him and his
cause in a clash of kings
roger castle attempted to put an end to
rems and his atrocities
rojak's party comes across ramsay during
one of his hunting trips
but ramsay is able to survive by
searching clothes with his personal
servant
who is then killed in his place
basically ramsey gave his clothes and
markings of identity
where upon roger's man killed that
servant believing him to be ramsay
another example can be found in last
fight between robber royce the last of
bronze kings
and artist serene the founder of house
seren it says it was dusk when artists
and his
antl army finally appeared but even in
that fading light roberoys did not fail
to mark their leader
his silvered armor and winged hell made
the falcon knight unmistakable
even from afar after the first six
charges against robert's line failed
artist falcon-shaped helmet appeared in
the heat of the battle
robert charged at him in the hope that
the andal army would dissolve
if their ruler was killed there we had
to leg their heroes meeting and fighting
in a duel
except for a fact one of them was just
an ordinary knight
robar beheaded the falcon knight after
duel only to see
500 fresh chandeliers charging at him
with artists terrain in their head
cunning even more than brute force
artists had cleared one of his knights
in his own distinctive armor to distract
robar
afterwards artists became the king of
the mountain in the veil and found in
house arena
those are only a few examples of someone
else wearing their hero's iconic armor
to sacrifice his life for him and his
cause there's obviously a reason why
george r martin is giving us these
examples
there's also one detail from the episode
blackwater that supports this theory
when that episode came out george armand
was pretty upset that main characters
like stannis and the hound
were not wearing their helmets during
the battle aju explained that it would
be hard for people to make out who each
character is with their helmets on
at first glance it might seem strange
that george would complain about such a
small detail
but it actually makes perfect sense for
him to later reveal that rhaegar never
fought robert on the trident a big deal
would obviously be made about one member
of the king's guard wearing gregor's
armor and helm
after the fall of house targaryen and
world believing him dead
in this theory rhaegar went to braavos
in the house of black and white to
become a faceless man
just as zarya stark did when her house
fell and when everyone thought she was
dead
if rhaegar is not in fact joking it
would also be very strange that some
random faceless man would allow himself
to be captured and thrown into black
cells
without a good reason however if it
truly is rehgar then he had a very good
reason to be captured
which is returning a favor to ned stark
or protecting his child
as we all know when jorn requests
prisoners to take the black
the black cells are emptied out and
jackie hagar is among the prisoners
jackie accompanies this group all the
way to harehole where he begins to form
a special bond vitaria
now you might be wondering why would
rehgar help arya she's the daughter of a
man who helped robert baratheon usurp
his family's claim to the armed round
bell rhaegar never held that against ned
since it's his father who killed ned
stark's father and brother
and even requested nets and robert's
heads sonnet did not really have a
choice
also as i already said rhaegar kind of
owed ned to protect arya
since ned had protected his sunshine
it's definitely not out of the realm of
possibilities that rhaegar came back to
king's landing as joking
to try and help protect a child of a man
who's the sole reason his son john is
alive and well
it's also quite interesting how it seems
like joking solyena and arya from the
very start
in one of their conversations jaqen says
to arya a girl has more courage than
sense
this sentence was also accompanied with
a smile on his face
everyone who knew lyna claims that tary
is just like her not only by looks but
also by courage and wildness
this is what ned said to arya arya you
have a violence in your child
the whole blood my father used to call
it lyanna had a touch of it
my brother brandon more than a touch it
brought them both to an early grave
lyanna might have carried a sword if my
lord father allowed it
you remind me of her sometimes even look
like her that continued
so rhaegar not only helps arya but he
also later trains her to become someone
she just like her aunt lienna always
wanted to be
a person capable of defending herself
and her family
it's also important to highlight that if
joking is some random faceless man
assassin
he would not be happy and proud of arya
when sure he claimed her stark name
and rejected to be no one neither would
he allow her to leave
an actor who plays jackie hagar recently
sat down in an interview
and he had a couple of interesting
things to say he only added fuel to
flame and he said if you change the
orders of the letters of jogging agar he
leaves rhaegar
and people began to try to justify the
jockey was regarded with photos
long hair his grace he teased might
regard truly be alive and he is a
character no one expects to see in the
finale
maybe an actor who plays rhaegar did
hang around the same set and hotels
other actors were staying at
so maybe he truly did shoot a few scenes
and maybe rehgar will actually reappear
we'll see many fans have always believed
jockey was rekkar
the silver streak in his hair perhaps he
became no one when westeros was being
torn apart by war
and use his other faces to hide his true
identity until the time is right
maybe he's so close to arya because she
resembles lyanna
and as always i hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you did please make sure
to subscribe to our channel and i hope
to see you in the next one
peace